los primeros días desde que expiró el
título 42 no han traído la cantidad de
cruces irregulares que muchos esperaban
según el departamento de seguridad
nacional la cantidad de personas que
buscan ingresar por la frontera
disminuyó un 50% En comparación con los
días finales de la medida implementada
durante la pandemia las causas que
impulsan a miles a migrar sin embargo
siguen intactas y es importante señalar
que si bien el título 42 ha terminado
las condiciones que están causando la
migración hemisférica a niveles sin
precedentes no ha cambiado continuamos
viendo más personas desplazadas en el
hemisferio que en décadas pero estamos
trabajando en estrecha colaboración con
nuestros socios extranjeros para abordar
estos movimientos al proporcionar vías
legales proteger a los migrantes
vulnerables y hacer cumplir sus propias
fronteras los diferentes estados
continúan adaptando sus políticas para
la acogida de migrantes es el caso de
Nueva York que alistó una docena de
escuelas públicas y prepara el hotel
Roosevelt para que sea el primer centro
de admisión para solicitantes de asilo
tras el fin del 42 quedó en vigor el
título 8 los pueden pedir asilo dentro
de Estados Unidos pero ser elegible es
más difícil
sonado ahora tienen que someterse a una
investigación pero por lo general No
tendrán derecho a asilo A menos que
cumplan una de las excepciones limitadas
una de esas excepciones es que hayan
concertado una cita para solicitar asilo
en la frontera a través de una nueva
aplicación para teléfonos inteligentes
llamadas cvp One y la otra gran
excepción es si habían conseguido
solicitar asilo en otro país y se les
había denegado de camino a Estados
Unidos
miles de migrantes tratan de seguir las
reglas aplicando a través de la
aplicación cvp One una aplicación que
denuncian no funciona correctamente y
donde las pocas plazas disponibles se
evaporan en cuestión de minutos